[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
y me acompaña esta mañana en el estudio
Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo bienvenido
Que bueno tenerlo por acá en directo
América edición matinal hablamos de
Reino Unido porque esta mañana en ese
país se cayó la libra esterlina Qué pasó
estaba de Juan Pablo Raúl buenos días
Gracias por la bienvenida pues la caída
llegó luego de que el gobernador del
banco de Inglaterra anunciara que no
extenderá el plan de compra de deuda de
emergencia que presentó el mes pasado el
cual recordemos tenía como objetivo
estabilizar los mercados financieros el
gobernador dijo que ese plan va solo
hasta este viernes 13 de octubre con
esto con esto la libera esterlina cayó
casi un 1% frente al Dólar hasta los
1,10 dólares recordemos que la moneda
local de Reino Unido ya había tenido una
leve recuperación de la caída histórica
del pasado 26 de septiembre luego de que
el gobierno de la Recién llegada primera
ministra listros anunciara planes de
recortes de impuestos por 50 mil
millones de dólares Sin dar mucha
explicación de cómo se financiarían
estos planes estas fueron las palabras
del gobernador del banco de Inglaterra
esencialmente Ahora hay una ventana de
oportunidad para que los fondos de
pensiones hagan Este reequilibrio pero
como has dicho Tim hemos tenido que
volver a ser más intervenciones en el
mercado incluso nos mantuvimos
despiertos toda la noche de ayer para
hacer una nueva intervención como banco
de Inglaterra nos dimos cuenta de que
por motivos de estabilidad financiera
teníamos que hacerlo porque los fondos
de pensiones son los propietarios
naturales de esas cosas y vamos también
con una información que adelantábamos en
nuestros rondas informativas en directo
América Juan Pablo porque a pesar de que
el gobierno francés pidió a los
trabajadores de la refinerías regresar a
trabajar ellos se rehúsan Así es Raúl
pues ayer la ministra la primera
ministra de Francia Elizabeth born
anunció la requisición del personal de
la refinerías pero esta madrugada los
trabajadores votaron por seguir la
huelga los sindicatos han exigido
incrementos salariales que no han sido
bien recibidos por los directores de las
empresas y desde el lunes el gobierno
empezó a ver con lupa este problema
realizando constantes reuniones de
emergencia las huelgas son paralizado 6
de las siete refinerías de combustible
en Francia causando la escasez del
hidrocarburo y empeorando aún más la
situación con las compras desesperadas
de abastecimiento de los franceses el
sindicato francés de trabajadores cgt
afirmó que imprimirá ante los tribunales
las notificaciones de requisición del
gobierno escuchemos
como han visto la huelga se renovó por
mayoría Entonces ahora vamos a volver a
ver a la gerencia pedimos una reunión
ayer pero lamentablemente el director
estaba ausente nos dijeron que nos
veríamos hoy Entonces vamos a ir a
informarles sobre las demandas de los
empleados Juan Pablo seguimos en Europa
porque pese al panorama de inflación y
crisis energética en ese continente la
producción industrial de zona Euro sigue
en aumento siguen aumento un dato que
pues al parecer no se esperaba y que
repuntó muchísimo la producción de la
industria de los 19 países que comparten
el euro como moneda se disparó en agosto
Comparado con el mes anterior el aumento
de la eurozona fue del
1,5% en agosto frente a Julio si miramos
casos particulares en el caso de Francia
aumentó
2,5%. Italia tuvo un incremento del
2,3%, pero Alemania en cambio disminuyó
un
0,5%. pero volviendo al panorama de toda
la zona Euro el cual fue de positivo
experto señalan que el resultado se debe
a que los fabricantes realizaron grandes
inversiones En sus empresas pese a los
temores de recesión que muy bien hemos
hablado aquí Raúl que pues se ven
hablando desde varios meses los
fabricantes produjeron más bienes de
consumo y mermaron su producción de
energía Claro está por toda la crisis
energética y pues su relación con Rusia
evidentemente dejamos a Europa nos
venimos a nuestra región porque
finalmente el senado chileno aprobó el
acuerdo transpacífico tras cuatro años
en tramitación Así es Raúl el senado
chileno aprobó el que está considerado
como el tercer acuerdo comercial más
grande del mundo pero que genera gran
polémica en el país vigente desde 2018
este acuerdo Busca eliminar o reducir
barreras arancelarias en los 11 países
miembros y abarca un mercado de casi 500
millones de personas esto representa el
13% del pib mundial para los detractores
del acuerdo quitará soberanía económica
y otorgará a las transnacionales
derechos a demandar a los Estados en
Estancia arbitrarias internacionales
pero los defensores resaltan que abre
puertas a la exportación sin aranceles
de más de 3000 subproductores y que
generaría ingresos anuales para Chile
que rondan los Oiga esa cifra 1.200
millones de dólares la cámara de
diputados lo aprobó en 2019 y traspasar
varios años en un cajón el senador
retomó a finales de septiembre su
discusión el acuerdo puede ser
promulgado por el mandatario chileno
pero el trámite sería inmediato porque
chile envió una serie de cartas a 10
países miembros que lo extienden en el
proceso hablabas de cifras Juan Pablo lo
que más me gustaba esta sección es la
cifra del día que nos trae hoy usted
tiene tiktok Sí señor Claro que sí pues
escucha porque puede que le recorte si
usted no se genera ingresos por ahí
se queda hasta con el 70% de las
ganancias que reciben las familias
desplazadas en los campamentos sirios
por medio de transmisiones en vivo que
realizan a través de la plataforma Pero
cómo acceden a tiktok que estas personas
Pues por medio de intermediarios que
trabajan con agencias afiliadas a esta
empresa en China y medio oriente Y cómo
sucede esto de las ganancias para las
familias Pues los niños sirios
transmiten durante horas en la
plataforma suplicando por obsequios
digitales de espectadores en una
situación de vulnerabilidad y pues estos
obsequios tienen un valor puntual y les
llegan directamente a las familias en
una en una transmisión de una hora la
bbc descubrió que llegan a ganar hasta
mil dólares pero de eso la familia solo
se queda con 300 dólares es decir el 70%
para tik Tok tiktok ha dicho que esta
práctica pues la llamo como mendicidad y
que no estaba permitida en su plataforma
para que no pida dinero por ti claro lo
están entonces castigando por esa
práctica pero igual 70% es bastante Juan
Pablo Gracias por toda la información
más adelante por supuesto más economía
vamos ahora a saludar huma